a baton switch that was teased in the
trailer and an altogether different
origin from his comic book counterparts
it's time to talk about the big twist
Major Spoilers for Black Adam ahead
Train The Rock Johnson has promised a
change of pace for the DC extended
Universe which has so far failed to
truly compete with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe however Black Adam may not be
the success that Warner Brothers needs
it to be while the movie debuted to
genuinely positive responses from fans
it has since Fallen to a gnarly 42 on
Rotten Tomatoes meanwhile The Verge
suggested that the film has an
insatiable need to show how cool murder
can be over telling a compelling story
throughout its two-hour run time Black
Adam shoves a lot of information at the
audience the movie hits the ground
running opening with teth Adam's
supposed origin story then jumping ahead
to the present day it's there that were
introduced to the film's human
protagonist mother and son Adriana and
Amman followed by supergroup the Justice
Society but the film's most significant
plot twist happens during its numerous
flashbacks to the champion end of condog
from the beginning Black Adam introduced
his audience members to the plot line
surrounding the titular anti-heroes
Origins the movie opens with a flashback
to 2600 BC when the ruthless King on cot
Enslaved the people of conduct forcing
them to mine the country's natural
resource a powerful substance called
eternium a young boy attempts to Sage a
revolution to free his people from
slavery but uncut soldiers capture the
boy and sentenced him to death before
the soldiers construct the killing blow
the boy receives the powers of Shazam
becoming the champion of conduct which
he uses to kill the king and end his
Reign before being entombed the event
goes down in condox history inspiring
its citizens as they go through endless
phases of occupation by different forces
it's not until the Justice Society
arrives that we're finally given more
details about the champion when Hawkman
reveals a Black Adam nearly destroyed
conduct which resulted in his
imprisonment not entombment later in the
film Black Adam reveals that he's not
the legendary champion of conduct a
young boy that fueled the nation's
Revolution and received the powers of
Shazam was in fact Adam's son her root
as the champion her root was invincible
so the King's Men attacked his family
instead to save his father from certain
death her Roots transferred his powers
to Adam my son sacrificed his life to
save me
unfortunately this gave the Assassins
the opportunity they needed to kill her
Roots a rage-filled Adam uses his new
powers to get revenge for his son's
death destroying most of Khan dog before
being brought in front of the Wizards of
Shazam the Wizards deem him unworthy to
hold the powers and imprison him for
Eternity Black Adam takes much of its
inspiration from DC Comics New 52 run of
the character though the comic book
origin is a bit darker than Dwayne
Johnson's portrayal well Johnson's comic
book counterparts doesn't have a son
named her root his nephew Amana played a
significant role in his origin story in
the newly reset DC Universe Black Adam
was given a new spin on his origin story
in Justice League volume 2. this version
of teth Adam was also enslaved in
ancient Khan dark by the nation's
dictator murdered his entire family
leaving only his nephew Oman drawing
their escape Adam receives a
life-threatening injury before the
wizard Shazam transports the two to the
rock of Eternity there the wizard deems
a man worthy of the powers of Shazam
tasking him with three in conduct Amman
agrees but only if the wizard heals Adam
a mom receives the powers and The Wizard
heals and strengthens Adam I kneel
before no one Adam and Amman travel back
to Khan dark but disagree about how to
use their newly acquired Powers well
Adam wants to exact Revenge by killing
the dictator a man seeks a more peaceful
solution fearing that a man's plan won't
work Adam kills his nephew and steals
his powers claiming he did it for the
greater good he becomes a mighty Adam
and goes out in history as a champion
that freed Khan dark similar to Black
Adam the comics say that the champion
disappeared however Adam turned against
the Council of Eternity that gave him
his powers and killed them the wizard
Shazam the only surviving member manages
to imprison him subsequently dubbing him
Black Adam
[Music]